the armel center in southern beirut
provides refugees with medical help as
well as a place to socialize and learn a
new trade so they can find work
mona is training to be a beautician and
hopes to open her own shop
one day
for now she says life is difficult
our husbands can't find work it's the
wives who have to look after the
families
mona fled to beirut from syria two years
ago now she lives near the center with
her four children
it's through local relief projects like
this that international aid reaches the
refugees
once they reach lebanon refugees are
largely left to themselves
unlike its neighbours lebanon has made a
point of not setting up camps to stop
refugees from settling in for the long
haul
in beirut germany's foreign minister
frank walter steinmeier is keen to
stress that his country has taken in
more than one hundred thousand syrian
refugees
that's more than any other country
outside the region
we need to share this challenge more
evenly there needs to be willingness
from european countries to do more for
syrian
refugees so far germany has spent over a
billion euros supporting syrian refugees
and their host countries
but that's not going to be enough as
long as the international community does
nothing to end the bloody conflict at
the root of this refugee crisis